today's quote comes from the zen page a
day calendar
my life is my practice
that's by rom das big shout out to rom
you know what i'm saying i hope he's
listening big shout out what does that
mean to you jb
it's so poignant people say that [ __ ]
all the time poignant
something you do in life for a reason
that wind up preparing you
for something else you are [ __ ]
constantly in a state of practice and
[ __ ]
doing [ __ ] sometimes you do [ __ ] miles
and you don't have no idea
that you're even [ __ ] doing it are
you sleepwalking or something oh you'd
be surprised
how many [ __ ] learn [ __ ]
sleepwalking one time i was sleepwalking
and i started playing chess and [ __ ]
with myself and i [ __ ] beat myself
so you weren't really walking you're
just sitting no i was playing chess and
sleep i'm sleep chester
that's even a term i don't think it is
oh here's the perfect analogy okay it
was a movie i grew up on
right i just love this [ __ ] movie
when i was at the school special movies
and [ __ ] you see episcopal specials
oh yeah i just [ __ ] love them they
come on right after school
exactly let's go home and watch the
absolute special there's one movie
called
james at 16. let me tell you how my life
is my practice
sometimes your hand is forced to learn
something
james at 16 was this movie about this
kid i don't know if you had a bladder
problem miles or grow up you know wet in
the bed and [ __ ] like that
were you a bed wetter yeah i mean at a
certain point i mean i i stopped
eventually yeah
so my [ __ ] diaper wetters and then
they they move on they don't wet
[ __ ] no more but some [ __ ] it's
like they're wearing a diaper for life
they can't stop [ __ ] peeing they
can't stop it miles
you know what i'm saying i mean i'm not
gonna [ __ ] lie i need to wet the bed
i didn't have a bed i used to wet the
tub my mom made my bed
in the tub so i wouldn't ruin no more
[ __ ] mattresses and [ __ ]
you ruined a mattress it's good thinking
[ __ ] yeah damn they're innovative my
mama's
innovative mm-hmm so james 16 his mom
hated the fact that he kept
[ __ ] urinating in the bed every
[ __ ] night i'm assuming he was 16 at
the time
[ __ ] yeah he was 16. so his mama hate
that [ __ ] she was a bad mama
a [ __ ] bad mama she calls him
basically
to piss on himself constantly you can
force the piss out of somebody
by your actions by how you treat them
you force their brain
to continue to do [ __ ] that you don't
want them to [ __ ] do
he urinated in the bed every [ __ ]
night his mom was [ __ ] evil she was a
mean ass lady so here's what she would
do
she would take his sheets from last
night and hang him out the window
and let people of the neighborhood see
his pissy ass
goddamn sheets terrible he was walking
home from school one day the sheet is
hanging out the window
and you couldn't even blame the [ __ ] or
anything else you couldn't say
oh that's lemonade you know because
lemonade and piss
are close in apple juice too yeah you
know how many times you can mistaken a
urine sample but apple juice
easily [ __ ] easily i think it's
almost a bigger problem
if you're spilling lemonade in your bed
every night like you pee
i get it but who would just keep
spilling beverages in their bed
every night maybe you don't have a
little tray to put the [ __ ] on anyway so
his mama hang his sheets out the window
let the sheets blow in the wind
so everyone can see my son she was
trying to force him
to not piss into bed so he saw this so
guess what he started doing this little
[ __ ] started running home from
school every day so he would beat
his classmates so they wouldn't walk
past his home and see
this [ __ ] sheet blowing around like a
goddamn flag and [ __ ] like a piss flag
a lot of baggage for that kid to carry
that's right yeah it [ __ ] with his
head
so james started running home every day
[ __ ] running home
every [ __ ] day all school year to
beat his schoolmates
from walking down past his home run in
the house went upstairs
running his room snatched his [ __ ] out
the window every [ __ ] day
even on weekends it didn't [ __ ]
matter he didn't want anyone to see
those pissy ass sheets and guess what
miles
what his life became his practice
this little [ __ ] james at 16
years old
became a track star this little
[ __ ] ran
every day he ran full [ __ ] speed the
only thing that would have slowed that
[ __ ] down
is if you do a few hurdles you know what
i mean like just do a few hurdles on the
sidewalk make that my [ __ ] jump you
know i mean that might have slowed him
down a little bit
but this [ __ ] would run and this
[ __ ] became a [ __ ]
world-class track star because his mama
would hang his she saw the [ __ ] one
see what i'm saying all right so first i
just thought you were
telling me about an old bad movie but i
feel like you brought this back you
brought it home